[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's scott van pelt the popular anchor
sports center he joins us on the program
good morning is that your study that
you're joining me from scott
um it's actually otis the dog's room
and he just lets me he lets me sit here
mostly if he if he gets upset he'll let
me know but yeah this is just a little
sunny little uh
sunny little wing of the home yes yeah
it looks like a study is what that would
be
does the dog do you think i study do i
sound like a man who studies
no no uh does your dog do any tricks
scott
no he just sits there uh he lounges in
the sun and he listen he's nine and a
half he's been through some stuff man
he's just gonna hang out and that's what
we're we're we're good with that
how are you celebrating the one year
anniversary of the day the sports world
the night the sports world died
i'm gonna watch games and i'm gonna show
highlights of games
are you kidding me i mean it's it it's
so surreal dan to remember
and you you're one of the few people who
truly truly truly could appreciate
how surreal it is when you go upstairs
and sit down to prepare to do
what in our business is called a fill
right in between the nuggets
and the mavericks and the pelicans and
the kings you go up to phil
and then there's not a fill there's a
show because they're not playing
everything stopped and you're just kind
of making it up as you go it was
it was astounding and it's wild to
remember it um
and i i really i truly will just
celebrate by
being able to go in tonight and and do
all these games and
be thankful that we have sports to to
watch and to discuss
a lot of times we would go to
sportscenter and you're not dressed to
go on the air because
the show was going to be a couple hours
later you might have
a suit on or you might have you're not
tie your tie you don't have makeup on
you're not ready to go on the air
and then all of a sudden when do you get
the heads up
you gotta go on the air as soon as
possible
well thankfully that evening i was doing
um i was doing the the half times
because on wednesdays
typically i would be doing the halftimes
of the nba games
and then whatever fill there was in the
middle and then we'd come on after the
last game
so for years dan i would just like like
i'd be
i'd dress for comfort right and i'd be
wearing whatever around the office but i
realized that
i just would forever be wasting time and
then i would be burman
it would be 10 50 950 and i'd be
sprinting in without a mic
on because i wasn't ready so i about i
don't know not long ago i just decided
to hell with it i'm going to wear a suit
when i show up
and particularly on a night like that
where i was going to be on early anyway
so thankfully that part of it was done i
was dressed to work i just didn't know
the work i was going to be asked to do
what were you told in your ear as as
you're filling
and you're out there and you're a man on
an island
how are you getting your information
well when
when it really like with the breaking
news part about the season going away
that that was the nba announces it and
woah just tweeting stuff out and we just
went up there and went on with him in
in this instance it's dave passion
richard jefferson they're in sacramento
and we're waiting for the nightcap game
and then there's word that courtney
kirkland the official had refereed the
uh
officiated the utah game and the
pelicans were like well we're not
playing
and we're and it's like in my in my ear
my producer marco alfanderi saying
we're hearing that the pelicans aren't
going to play and i'm thinking well that
doesn't sound good
and i'm thinking i mean you're
processing this in real time you've been
in that chair
uh so many times you know immediately oh
i guess we're just going to be on here
well
we don't have a a rundown because we
didn't have a show
we were on after that game so in my ear
they're saying okay
i think dave and uh and richard are
gonna they're gonna fill for a minute
and then they're gonna come to us
and like panic isn't something that that
sets in often but in that moment like
they're going to come to us
to do what and
and then you just you've been in that
again there's so few people that truly
could get what that moment is
you just go into okay this is true
i think your audience understands right
they're going to come along with you
they they know that this isn't
the plan and you go to woach and then
you go to
royce young who's in oklahoma city where
the jazz are still
in the in the locker room and you go to
malika who's in new york city and she's
talking to players all around the league
and you just kind of ping pong back and
forth
um but what was crazy
if it's you and keith when keith's
talking your producer can talk to you
but when it's just you i don't have
anywhere to go
like they i can't kind of lay out and
let them say hold on america i need to
find out what the belief i'm doing here
give me a second
you're just kind of and at one point we
threw to some
sound of mark cuban and that was the
only time
in the entire time we were on where
i actually i don't know what mark cuban
said he could have said
anything he could have declared war on
chile i
could've said anything i didn't hear a
word because at that point
i'm listening to marco he's like all
right here's what we've got and you're
just
feverishly scribbling things down um but
looking back on it the thing that our
producer because we just did a podcast
where we kind of
pieced this all together and and our
producer who did an amazing job that
night said
the thing he's proud of is that we were
pretty measured we didn't i mean we kind
of kept it together
and that night i think we we as a group
got praised for not being hysterical and
and
so yay for that but i mean you just
those aren't cards you expect to play
ever and that's what happened and
nobody's a covet expert back then
we're just learning about it like we
don't think anything about a game being
cancelled now
but back then wait a minute they're not
going to play
wait what's that mean and then contact
tracing like what's
what's all of this mean and then you you
have to do a cliff notes version of
i need to know everything about covid as
soon as possible
without question and and and i don't
want to
i let's we understand how serious this
was is and has been right okay
no question but in mid-march of 2020
knowing as little as we knew and with
testing taking as long as it did like
you couldn't
go i mean how many i've gone and gotten
rapid tested you know
they tell you five minutes later yay or
nay well then we didn't know how long it
would take and i think there was
this true fear then if you got it
well maybe maybe you're in big trouble
and you know you picture like a
contagion right like you
i imagine the jazz with hazmat suit
people
and helicopters hovering overhead in the
military outside saying don't let the
jazz leave
well that wasn't what it was but we
didn't really know did we
and so it was it was definitely a
frightening time it felt inevitable that
someone in sports would get it but you
know what's fascinating dan
is that truly that was the moment that
everything pivoted in our country
the minute that that sport stopped being
played is the minute everyone was like
all right
we're just we're not doing this anymore
and we just sort of stopped
for a bit yeah that's when it i think it
it hit people how serious covet was
there's no sports like it almost took
that for people to understand boy this
is
really important but you know when you
work late at night you count on those
highlights
yes you do so you get a little
you know it's a little dry when you know
we're
we're little yeah from from that night
until july when we finally
mercifully took a bit of time away which
was our schedule we're supposed to take
some time off
after the nba finals in the beginning of
free agency
well from march 11 until early july we
did sportscenter every night
and there were no sports and uh
thank god for the last dance in the the
jordan dock which we could build around
thank god for zoom calls i mean i've
talked as i know you have i mean i've
talked to athletes on their
couch and their kitchen and their cars i
mean people you know
it's funny it's it works a lot better
these days just hey can you come on the
show i
you know i can't get to a studio you
have a studio in your pocket
just fire up face time man you can you
can come on with us
we we we figured it out but
it was look you and i know both
well the doing highlights sitting around
watching games it's stealing money okay
but for that four month time i'd like to
think whatever money i stole i paid back
i'm good with the cos with the cosmos
man i'm good with the world our our bill
is
even because those four months were um
you know
really really challenging scott van pelt
from the mother ship joining us on the
program
um who came up with senior night
well that was it was a collaborative
that the night after
thursday right wednesday not good
thursday we find out no tournament
um and and after our show meeting
we sit down as a group in this big
conference room you were there when you
came back that great night
uh you know our group and we got a great
group and we as you do
and we sit around and like what are we
gonna do because this is gonna suck
all right but what can we do to do
something positive
and so i started thinking out loud about
the idea of
just shine on shine a light on people
that didn't get a chance to have to say
goodbye
well i get home that night and there's
this note
from our a group in social that said
we've been talking about this idea
and jimmy pataro our boss president of
espn
independent of all of us three different
groups of people all were thinking along
the same lines
and so i sent out a tweet and i said
here's what we want to do
we want to we want to tip our caps to
the people who didn't get that chance
and there was this one kid in illinois
that there was a picture that just
really got me thinking about it because
his he was a game away from he and his
team are a game away from the state
finals
and they canceled it and he's sitting
alone in a gym at midcourt and i'm
thinking can you imagine that
and i couldn't and so out of
a lot of people just sort of kicking
around an idea we said who you know
share with us your stories
and it was the most amazing thing um
tens of thousands of people from all
over the country their high school
girls basketball team and boys and track
and hockey and baseball and lacrosse and
all and on and on
and we shared as many of those stories
as we could and what's really cool and
we're going to do it this week
is we're going to revisit that because
already we're getting we're getting
notes from
the jones high school girls basketball
team in oklahoma
they made it last year they didn't get
to play they made it again
so they're get they're back and this
year we're going to play and it's just
it's really cool like for the kids that
moved on they didn't get it but for
those communities
and the people who maybe had it cut
short last year they're gonna get to run
it back this year
so to me it'll be a fun way to to
revisit that but it was
it was really gratifying it was
gratifying because you know this dan
like sportscenter's not the end-all
be-all and espn is not the only thing in
the world but it's a
it's a pretty bright light it's a pretty
loud mic and when you talk into that mic
people hear you all around the country
and when those young people felt like
they were seen
and their accomplishments were being
recognized it mattered
and to be the person to share that
really really was gratifying
and we keep talking about this new
normal i don't know what the new normal
is
i don't know if you know just being able
to go to a game
like like that that simple pleasure
is not so simple but i don't know what
that feeling is going to be like
i haven't been on a plane in over a year
well
i haven't gone anywhere i haven't done
anything you know i'm still waiting to
get the vaccine
but there's part of me as just a fan
that i think i took
you know i was numb to it that we
we get to go to any game we want and we
get press passes and
i just want to go to a game and sit and
have a beer
and watch a game with other people
i want to hear them that's what i want i
miss the sound
there's nothing like the sound and
and i'm with you i i
you know what's wild is when you see an
old like
watching like a video of an old playoff
game and say like
yankee stadium like old yankee stadium
it looks like there are
400 000 people right it's just like god
look at all those people
and you miss that you miss being part of
the organic of what that is and to be
part of the roar or to hear it and it's
just
in the building or in a stadium so i'm
with you i i
look forward to that and i'm i'm hopeful
man i you know
i look i hope you get the shot soon my
mom got hurt soon as soon as we can get
ours
we'll get them and it feels like things
are easing
you know you don't get reckless here but
i i do feel like truly
a year afterwards not i never imagined
then we'd be a year in
you know having to deal with it but do
you share that do you share the optimism
that
that i mean sounds really corny but like
the better day is almost here it feels
like the home stretch
but i mean i'm just
i don't know i i it's a cautionary tale
and and every time you it's two steps
forward
and then it feels like it's two steps
back and now
maybe it's two steps forward one step
back i want to take two steps forward
and
take two more steps forward after that
like that
that's that's what i want and you know
what i don't miss scott
what the gallery at a golf
tournament i did not miss hearing some
idiot yell out get in the hole at the
arnold palmer invitational
so one of the few benefits of coaching
potatoes
mashed potatoes baba i did not miss that
at
all and uh so that that's the one of the
few benefits of covid was i didn't hear
the gallery
yeah but you know what if the trade-off
is that you get to go to a game you know
you just
just tune out tune out the guy that's 12
beers in screaming get in the hole he's
like hey buddy it's like a 480 yard part
that's a little ambitious well it is
dashambo so you can
say get in the hole
by the way otis nailed this interview
your dog was he's
he's he's not as as always that's his
resting posture so he's good he's
you know i work with people at
sportscenter coordinating producers who
were about as active as
otis was at about as bright right wow
wow wow you have to show up today i
don't
yeah you were talking you i was talking
about your question oh
no we no i don't have coordinated i have
uncoordinated producers
so that's a great group and it's always
good to be with you guys dan thank you
van peezy uh great to talk to you buddy
thank you you're welcome uh scott van
pelt sportscenter anchor